- [Gary] What's coming for
my heart right now is maybe
watching this and saying
maybe I need to hedge.
You know if you work from 8 PM
to four in the morning
will your dreams come true?
No. You might not
be good enough.
You might've not have
picked the right product.
But are we living in a world in
2012 that so much better than
your parents and grandparents
and great grandparents
generation because assholes
like me can make videos when I'm
30,000 fucking feet in the air?
Yes.
And because of that and because
of those opportunities and
because we're networked in a way
that we never seen before and
because sending an email to 100
people and one will answer and
give you a shot matters
because of that opportunity
because of 2012 I beg you,
I beg you to take a shot.
(somber piano music)
- [Gary] Let me tell you a thing
I don't talk about a whole lot
that I've talked about a little
bit if you really follow me
which is the following;
In my 20s, I spent an enormous
amount of time hanging out
with 90-year-old people.
A lot. It was a strategy.
I was like fuck it
these people did it.
Right? Let's see what
they have to say.
- [Brian] What happened last night
in Soho in the middle of London?
I'm watching you on Periscope
you kinda have this flash mob
and you put it out on
Snapchat and hundreds
of people were there
on a Tuesday night at 10:30.
- [Gary] Last night was
something I probably will,
it's funny I told the team I
will fundamentally remember
this night my whole life.
Last night, I did something I
haven't done in a long time.
Early Twitter 2007, 2008 I could
Tweet and say I'm going to a
pizza shop and 20 people would
show up and it'd be incredible.
Obviously I'm doing a big book
signing event in London today
and I saw a lot of people
tweeting and snapping and
Instagraming that they were
disappointed that they couldn't
make it so I'm like you know
what put out on Snapchat I said
hey after dinner I'm
going to pick some spot,
come and meet me.
10 PM Soho area
more details to come.
And I put that on Snapchat and
Instagram and we sat and had
dinner we were debating
how he would show up.
If I would have tweeted this I
mean you saw it this is been
more time but that seven or
eight would have been 20.
And I was like, man, if 50
people show up then I feel like
my brand is really
doing something.
Something is happening here.
Those 250, 300 people it
was complete insanity.
It was super humbling.
It started at 10:30 at night,
we were there until
1:30 in the morning.
People literally stood there for
an hour and a half, two hours,
three hours just to take a
selfie or ask a question.
Steve Ross is my business
partner he's 75 years old.
- [Man] My god.
- [Gary] He's fucking on fire.
I could text him right now
and he'll be like fucking what?
75--
- [Man] That's how I feel.
- [Gary] You've got minimum,
minimum 20 prime years.
Forget about years, prime.
I don't even know how to
put into words the level of
gratitude and humility that you
have to feel as a human being
that a couple of hours in a
country you don't live in
that people would show
up to that level.
It was a super cool
night for me, man.
- [Man 2] I'm just glad I got to
have this conversation with you.
I've dreamed this so many times.
- Thank you, brother.
- I appreciate it.
- Thank you so much, man.
- You told people last
night it's not about money.
What do you want to do?
You want to change the world?
Okay, then you go do that.
- That was interesting
moment with those two girls.
Like what you want?
Because if you want...
They're like we
want to help people.
You don't need any money
really to help people.
I live in an apartment now.
It's crazy to me that I
don't need a big house.
You grow up, you
don't need a lot of room.
With less room
you'll need less stuff.
I don't need five
70 inch TV screens.
I don't need a watch,
I don't even wear a watch.
I don't need a cool watch.
I don't need a boat.
I need the game.
I know myself.
And that's how I act.
Other people want things
that they don't really need.
Things that aren't
going to make them happy.
They're not fulfilled inside.
I'm always trying to challenge
people to get to their true self
because once you
understand yourself.
DRock loves to tell stories in
video form. Then do that.
Self-awareness is maybe you
should be number two,
number five, number seven,
number twelve, maybe should be
an accountant not an entrepreneur
because you could become the CFO
of an entrepreneur's
company and make $1 billion.
Number 72 at Facebook made a lot
more money than number one of
almost every business that has
come out in the last 10 years.
To me self-awareness is what are
you good at, what do you like,
what puts you in a
position to be successful.
I mean I have some entrepreneur
friends, I have one relative
entrepreneur friends that I
think they should
be a full-time mother.
I think she's
making a huge mistake.
She stinks as an entrepreneur.
She has incredible EQ
and amazing leadership.
I don't know.
You just don't meet 90-year-olds
that talk about how pumped they
are they made an extra
hundred thousand dollars.
They don't exist.
- Right.
- They talk about
regret of not doing.
Go talk to 90-year-olds.
They regret.
They talk about regret.
I wish I did,
literally, inevitably I do this.
"I wish" is the opening line.
Hey man, tell me
about your life.
This is what I do.
This what I did in my 20s.
I spoke to a lot of old people.
They lived it.
Literally, I wish.
One by one, at airport at
airport, park or park,
event or event, bar or bar
every one of them,
all of them started with I wish.
All of them.
I wish.
They grew up in a generation
that did not have the Internet.
It was not practical to do
all the amazing things
we can be doing.
They all wished.
They wished they work harder.
They wish they spent more
time with their family.
They wish they didn't
listen to their mom and
did what they wanted to do.
- I flew down without
my mom even knowing it.
- [Man] He flew
in just for this.
- My mom didn't
want to let me go.
Last day, I keep on pushing,
keep on pushing,
keep on pushing. She let's
me go. Now, I'm here.
- They wished,
they wished, they wished.
The biggest poison
in us is regret.
It's poison.
And I push so hard, so hard and
will through my vehicle
which isn't meditation,
which isn't health and wellness,
which isn't nonprofit.
My vehicle's business.
I can't help it.
It's what I love.
I love building businesses
I love competing with you.
I want to beat you.
I love that game but through
that vehicle I will always push
a lack of regret and awareness
to how good it really is.
You're more than welcome to
tell me how bad it is or
why you can't because or
what but it's just not true.
Because if anybody ever
did it then you can too.
- [Man and Gary]
(speaking Polish)
- [Gary] What does that mean?
- Hustle.
We're trying to find three
different words to describe.
- To describe it.
- But in some parts we
just left hustle and hustler.
- You're going to to try and
establish the word--
- Yes.
- in Poland. I like that.
- Hustle meaning
this, this and this.
Then we're using hustle
(speaking Polish) to be
different versions in context.
- I like it. I like it.
- What do you mean by hustle?
What is your
definition of hustling?
- To me it's an adjective.
It's a word that represents
working hard and smart,
competitively. Doing
whatever it takes to succeed.
It's me Gary did in the book is
now available on Amazon India.
I just tweeted it, check it.
And so I leave you with this if
you leave with anything tonight
it's stop making excuses.
Stop complaining.
Nobody's listening.
They may make pretend
they're listening,
the market doesn't care.
What you need to do is
make one person happy, you.
Then you can make
everybody else happy.
You know why I like
making people happy?
'Cause I'm already happy.
You know it's cooler
than anything I think.
Talking been shit
and backing it up.
I think that's the coolest.
I just about when our
conversations when I'm like yeah
we'll definitely open London.
(Raisa laughing)
- Three years, three and half
years ago when it first came up.
I still remember it.
- I can't believe it's
so real. We did it.
And so I implore you to take
this last little rant and really
look at your fucking face.
And understand are you doing the
things that are putting you in a
position to succeed not just
in a business world but in life
because it's super important.
- In the building
Vayner World was a major success.
- Amazing.
- Six interviews--
- Six!
- Legendary.
- [Gary] Because, boy, when
you're happy in life
your fucking business can roll.
And so I'm just trying to figure
it out and I've been trying to
figure it out in front of
you for the last 7, 8 years.
Trying to figure out the unlocks
EQ, IQ, self-awareness, hustle.
I don't know what they are.
You know why 'cause,
like I told my man,
it's 330 different unlocks.
And so I'll go to all them.
They're all tried-and-true
and one might hit you.
Yeah it was hard work
because I'm actually lazy.
I talk a good game
but I'm full of shit.
Or it might be
something else but fuck.
One.
One fucking life.
One life my friends, one time
and, honestly, I'll leave you
with this because a
lot of you need it.
How you make your
money is more important
than how much you make.
(somber piano music)